ya tenemos mucha experiencia graficando
pero revisemos algunos aspectos más voy
a empezar entonces dibujando unos ejes
aquí tenemos el eje y
y este de aquí
es el eje x voy a poner etiquetas para
la escala este es uno
3 en el eje y escala va a ser del 0 al 9
y en unos momentos va a saber por qué
123456789 puse tan solo las etiquetas de
los múltiplos de 3 podría haber puesto
más tenemos aquí entonces un primer
cuadrante de un plano cartesiano común y
corriente y ahora gráfica hemos algunas
funciones graphic hemos una función
lineal como ye igual a x como es su
gráfica cuando x es igual a 1 es igual a
1 cuando x es igual a 2 y es igual a 2
cuando x es igual a 3 10 igual a 3 y
aquí la tenemos una línea recta es por
eso que se llama una función lineal y
así cualquier función lineal sigue es
igual a 2x tendría una recta con una
pendiente mayor si además le sumo dos
estaríamos trasladando la recta dos
unidades hacia arriba eso ya lo vimos
todas esas son funciones lineales vamos
a dejar la original
x
es decir que la función lineal más
simple aunque quizá sea igual a una
constante es más simple aún ahora vamos
a graficar también una cuadrática ye
igual a equis cuadrada y es por eso que
puse mi escala hasta 9 aquí cuando x es
igual a 0 y es igual a cero cuando x es
igual a 1 y es igual a 1 cuando x es
igual a 2 y es igual a 4 aquí lo tenemos
cuando x es igual a 3 y es igual a 9 que
es este punto que tenemos aquí así es
que la gráfica de ye igual a x cuadrada
es más o menos así es algo así y esto ya
lo hemos visto varias veces así es como
se vería y ya estamos acostumbrados a
reconocer esto como la gráfica de una
función cuadrática al igual que
reconocemos una recta con una función
lineal voy a poner esta línea con el
mismo verde y ahora hagamos algo
interesante voy a cambiar esto un poco
voy a graficar las mismas dos funciones
pero en vez de tener un eje que crece
linealmente voy a tener un eje y cuya
escala va a estar
por los valores elevados al cuadrado lo
que podríamos llamar un eje y cuadrática
déjame dibujarlo para que veas a lo que
me refiero digamos que aquí tenemos el
eje y y estoy haciendo mi mejor esfuerzo
porque me quede rector nos voy a hacer
aproximadamente del mismo tamaño en el
eje x voy a tener la misma escala de 1 a
aquí tenemos entonces 0 1 2 y 3 y en el
eje x lo que de hecho voy a tener déjame
etiquetarlo de la siguiente manera
primero voy a poner las marcas ahora
este no va a ser simplemente uno va a
ser uno al cuadrado que por supuesto es
uno la siguiente marca en vez de ser
simplemente dos va a ser dos al cuadrado
así es que es 4 y en desde que esta sea
3 va a ser 3 al cuadrado 9 observa que
es lo que está pasando aquí con la
escala del eje y en vez de que vaya
incrementándose de manera lineal se va
incrementando de manera cuadrática y
también puedo poner las marcas
medias aquí tenemos un medio al cuadrado
que es un cuarto que es 0.25 este es 1.5
al cuadrado que es 2.25 2.25 y este es
2.5 al cuadrado que es 6.25 de nueva
cuenta si me muevo cierta distancia en
este eje el incremento no va a ser por
la misma cantidad si por ejemplo si por
ejemplo me muevo desde cero hasta aquí
estoy incrementando en 1 ahora si me
muevo desde aquí hasta acá estoy
incrementando en 5 mientras que de aquí
hasta que esto incrementando en 3 aquí
incremento en 1 a quien 3 y aquí
incrementó en 5 a medida que cruce una
de estas etiquetas de referencia esto
incrementando cada vez más y más y más
de tal manera que la escala en el eje y
ya no es una escala lineal
esta es una escala que de alguna manera
podríamos llamar cuadrática en esta
escala cada etiqueta nos va a
representar el cuadrado de la distancia
correspondía
a diferencia de la escala acá donde cada
etiqueta indica precisamente la
distancia lo que es interesante aquí es
ver qué pasa cuando gratificamos estas
funciones en este nuevo plano coordenada
donde el eje x se incrementa de manera
lineal mientras que el eje y es
implementa de manera cuadrática veámoslo
esto es realmente interesante te invito
a que le pongas pausa el vídeo e
intentes hacerlo por tu cuenta
bien graphic hemos graphic hemos primero
llegó a la equis cuadrada que en este
caso surge más fácilmente cuando x es
igual a 0 x al cuadrado es cero cuando x
es igual a 0.5 x al cuadrado es 0.25
cuando x es igual a 1 x cuadrada es uno
cuando x es igual a 2 x cuadrada es 4
cuando x es igual a 3 x cuadrada es 9
y veamos lo que tenemos tenemos una
línea recta qué clase de magia negra
estoy haciendo bien en realidad esta
línea recta es la gráfica de i igual a x
cuadrada que estoy graficando recuerda
en una escala que ya no es lineal por lo
que ahora la gráfica es una línea recta
lo que es interesante o aún más
interesante es que pasa cuando gráfica
moss ya iguala x veamos cuando x es
igual a 0 y es igual a cero cuando x es
igual a 0.25 y es igual a 0.25 y estoy
eligiendo puntos de manera arbitraria de
tal manera que me sea más fácil graficar
los cuándo x es igual a 1 y es igual a 1
cuando x es igual a 2 y es igual a 2
cuando x es igual a 3 y es igual a 3
déjame graficar mejor estos puntos
cuando x es igual a 2 y es igual a 2 y
cuando x es igual a 3 y es igual a 3 y
como se ve esta gráfica esta gráfica se
va a ver más o menos así esta que es la
gráfica
ye igual a x se va a ver así por este
eje se va a ver así en este plano
coordinado con un eje lleno lineal esto
parece si tuviéramos un eje llega un
escala lineal parecería la gráfica de
igual a raíz de equis pero no lo es es
la gráfica de igual a x es la gráfica de
una función lineal que ya no se ve como
una recta pues la escala del eje y no es
lineal espero que esto amplia tu mente
para que consideres que hay muy diversas
clases de escalas es frecuente toparse
con diversos tipos de escalas hay
escalas logarítmicas hay escalas
exponenciales esto no es raro y en
general si tú cambias tu escala si
mantiene la escala en x lineal y
cambiarles callenger como hicimos en
este caso que hicimos una escala
cuadrática entonces la gráfica de una
función cuadrática es una línea recta
por otro lado si esta escala hubiera
sido logarítmica entonces las funciones
logarítmicas se verían como líneas
rectas cualquiera que sea el tipo de
escala del eje y mientras mantengas la
escala del eje x lineal entonces las
gráficas de ese tipo de funciones se va
como líneas rectas en estos locos ejes
coordinados